if I had no support or love or anything
from anyone I wouldn't tik-tok star
chase Hudson also known as little Hut II
breaks down while opening up about his
past experiences with bullying and
suicidal thoughts I did struggle growing
up as a child my teenage years really
hard the 18 year old says something
tragic happened to him when he was a
child and it reoccurs when he was 14
that was like to start immediately
losing feeling emotion just a lot of
like heartbreak I was always kind of a
misfit and very like judged and I looked
at that time she started to lean on
social media but he says it made him a
bigger target for bullies I did have
place a really bad a really bad freshman
year at a really bad sophomore year she
switched to online school as a sophomore
because I was I was bullied and told my
kid told to I killed myself for doing
social media every day I thought about
it a few times back when I was in the
middle school and like early high school
is just like why does anyone like Jace
everyone says pursue your dreams but
when you actually do it then you get
judged for it but the tic-tock Starr
says his fans got him through the worst
of it so she made it was kind of my
outlet same people care about me and
look up to me
during helps even says social media
quotes saved my life take the love and
the care and the nice message is you
guys leave me and it's everything you
guys really a lot for me chase says now
his life is pretty awesome since moving
into the hype house I moved out so late
now I live with all my friends realize
it looks pretty awesome I'll have to
deal with it anymore
like I could see the social media
comments but that doesn't mean anything
to me anymore cuz it's not like physical
one-on-one like someone's saying it to
your face which hertzel ours
but now that I'm out of the school space
it pays off and we have a feeling more
will pay off ET spoke with chase back in
February and he shared his future plans
a year from now getting into the music
space a little bit yeah that's all it's
all private at the moment it's in the
works
doing stuff in the fashion industry
going a bunch of shows